Laissez moi chanter
avec la guitare à la main
Je suis italien
Bonjour Italie, spaghetti al dente
et un partisan en tant que président
avec l'autoradio toujours dans la main droite
un canari au dessus de la fenêtre
avec l'Italie avec vos artistes
avec trop d'Amérique sur les affiches avec le
chansons avec amour avec coeur avec plus
de moins en moins de femmes sont religieuses
avec jours Italie Bonjour Maria avec
les yeux pleins de mélancolie Bonjour
Dieu
[Musique]
Tu sais que je suis là aussi
Laisse-moi
chanter
avec la guitare
loin
laisse-moi chanter une chanson doucement
sol
laissez moi chanter
parce que je suis fier de
Je suis italien
[Musique]
Un vrai italien
jours l'Italie qui n'a pas peur et avec
crème à raser menthe avec un
costume à fines rayures sur bleu et ralenti la
Dimanche à la télé
journées en Italie avec un petit café
pas de tiroir supérieur comme le drapeau
un atelier de carrosserie 600 down
[Musique]
jours Italie Bonjour Maria avec le
les yeux pleins de
mélancolique Bonjour Dieu
Tu sais que je suis là aussi
Laissez moi chanter
avec la guitare à la main
laisse-moi chanter une chanson doucement
sol
laissez moi chanter
parce que je suis fier de
Je suis italien
Un vrai italien
[Musique]
Laissez moi chanter
avec la guitare à la main
laisse-moi chanter une chanson
très silencieusement
laisse-moi
chanter
parce que je suis fier de
Je suis italien
[Musique]
Un vrai italien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]